Hello, everyone, we're here
at KubeCon in Barcelona.
With me is Aparna Sinha.
She is Director of Product Management
of Kubernetes and...
- Anthos.
- Anthos, that's right.
Can you start off telling us
what Anthos is?
Sure, Anthos is our hybrid Cloud offering
that's based on Kubernetes Istio
and our multicluster management
control plane that's hosted in the Cloud.
We're here at KubeCon.
This conference is all about open source.
How does GKE relate to open source,
and why is there
such a big presence of Google here?
Why the Google presence?
Google is the originator
of the Kubernetes project.
It came from our history with Borg
as you know.
We've been running containers
in production for 15 years now.
And we're launching billions
of containers, new containers,
every week, even today.
So that's why Google is here.
We're very, very passionate
about this project.
We have hundreds of engineers
and product managers
that are working on the project
and have been since the last five years.
As you know it's the fifth anniversary
of Kubernetes, and so we're having
a birthday celebration here.
It's also the fifth anniversary,
pretty soon, this year, of GKE.
So GKE was started pretty much
in parallel with Kubernetes.
It is our hosted version of Kubernetes
running in Google Cloud,
Google Kubernetes engine.
It is the oldest, most mature,
most stable, and widely used distribution
and hosted offering
of Kubernetes in use today.
So we're very, very excited
about both Kubernetes
as well as GKE, and they actually have
really built off of each other.
So another component of Anthos
that I'm really interested in is Istio.
Can you tell me more about that?
Yeah, as you move to microservices,
you find that you actually have
a lot of services in your environment,
and you need a good way
to manage those services.
And in particular, you want to be able
to monitor the services,
have observability about which services
are talking to which other services,
to be able to set policies
on those services
from a security perspective,
and to be able to control traffic
when you need to.
And this is the essential function
of an SRE inside Google,
you know, a site reliability engineer.
Developers are not typically the ones
that are making sure that the service
is up and running
or setting the security policies.
And with Istio and with Anthos,
in general what we do is we allow
the ability for that separation
of concerns, where you can have
an SRE or operator-type role
that is doing the service management,
that is taking care of monitoring,
securing, and ensuring the reliability
of your services
through that traffic management.
So that's the capability
that we provide with Istio,
and then the combination of that
and Anthos configuration management,
which lets you, from a single source
of truth, set policies,
both configuration policies,
security policies, RBAC,
quota-- these types of policies--
across your multicluster environment,
allows you to do that
from a single pane of glass.
That's really what enterprises need,
particularly as they have
these multiple environments,
whether they're
at different retail locations
or On-Prem, different data centers
and Cloud,
the configuration management capability
and the service management capability
is how they're able to standardize
and manage and have that operations team
that can take care of the environment,
freeing up the developers
to do their coding and take care
of the business functions
that their business requires.
So it sounds like the Anthos ecosystem
is going to provide a lot
of very awesome functionality
to customers very soon.
So last question is what
are you looking forward to
at KubeCon this week?
Well, I'm looking forward to your keynote.
That's definitely a big highlight.
I'm looking forward to meeting
a lot of the ecosystem
in the community here.
Another part of Anthos
is our marketplace,
so we've got a marketplace
in Google Cloud,
and what we've done actually
in our workloads team
is we've got the application object.
And we are working
with a lot of the community here,
a lot of the ecosystem,
to create containerized forms
of their applications,
whether it's in the form of operators
or it's just containers or some other
package that they want to use
and then publishing it to the marketplace
in GCP and that marketplace
is then available to all Anthos customers,
whether it's on GKE
or it's on GKE On-Prem,
and they can deploy those applications
out of the gate with support
from the ecosystem.
So we're really bringing the open source
ecosystem to Google Cloud users,
and I think that has
a multiplicative effect
and is a big reason to be here.
It's a big reason to really build on
what we've done with the community.
That's sounds awesome.
Thank you so much for your time, Aparna.
Thank you.
♪ (music) ♪